Julian Assange has been sleeping in the
in the bathroom and somebody found out
as I'm pretty sure I saw a guy in a
weird scarf in a trench coat earlier
enough did you is he wearing a skirt
he's boulders
oh he is he has like a little scarf
under his sweater some of his costumes
have like the whole like hey hey I'm a
robber thing yeah kevin conroy so kevin
vine or do you write here to show us
watch dogs what are we playing this on
at the moment I and this is an Xbox one
okay because this is the version we had
in the office I was going to show off
the PC version once I would not
necessarily recommend grabbing that
until the issues are fixed I have heard
there are some problems there are some
problems with you play okay so yeah I
you do now so right now we're playing on
that on Xbox one playing on an Xbox one
you've reviewed this and you enjoyed
this game I like this game a lot
absolutely yes it's a good it's a really
great sandbox to just tool around in and
make fun and I think I think that um
it's one of those games that actually
was hurt by its marketing yeah because
it was marketed so heavily as as being
like this super serious kind of spy game
Deus Ex II thing and it has parts of
that but really the things this game
does best is just being a really being a
really cool sandbox letting you t-bone
soccer moms soccer moms absolutely yeah
I think that's a really fair assessment
I played the first couple of hours
almost kind of I felt disappointed but
then after a while I'm kind of realizing
I was just anticipating a different game
the game is different than the one I
expected but once you're able to let the
expectation go I'd say that this this
game is right up there with with the the
big city based open-world heavyweights
awesome I'd say you know if you like
Saints Row and you like GTA it's almost
a given that you're probably going to
have a lot of fun with this game and if
you have any questions for Kevin about
watchdogs by all means stick them into
twitch Josh or on the GameSpot comments
if the site's back up or on Twitter and
we'll we'll get them sent over and how
far you through watchdogs demolish well
business this is the vert towards the
very beginning of the game hate you see
some people making out that is not
appropriate brother runs grow up grow up
just because his brother grows yeah he
recently went to Las Vegas house sitter
people do that for a living like all the
so those are two people that are not
actively doing horrendously crappy
amoral things no although I will say
that if you are if watchdogs is to be
believed then the people of Chicago are
usually engaged in terrible thing when
they think that they're not being
watched but they are but they are
bothersome dogs what are you doing what
mission is this you so this is a CTOs
tower so what this is is you have to
figure out how to get in there and so c4
hack into it and uh no that doesn't work
and then unlock go in that open gate
different parts of the of the of the
city like you this is basically like the
Far Cry Assassin's Creed tower type
thing so a lot of the times you can get
into like get into cameras in this case
you know the forklift might be in the
way of the switch you can get to our
case it was in the way of the camera
that you need to get to and there's the
unlock new driver San Francisco you're
way over I really basically that that's
probably I call that riding the cameras
it's like my little like that's not an
official term that's just what I call it
right sir yeah so you just ride the
cameras around this case a pretty pretty
easy route in there my favorite aspect
of that has been the CTOs like
headquarter areas where you have to like
hack into them not the towers but like
the the centers that they have no
totally and and like I remember turning
up outside one with all my guns and
thinking I'm going to have to shoot my
way through this and then never even
entering the area just using the cameras
and using almost like a puzzle game to
try and figure out the way of getting
over it yeah well even some of that you
can even approach some of the combat
encounters like that like you don't even
have to get sometimes you can solve
encounters without even getting into a
fight or having to do traditional
sneaking you can just find ways to go
through the cameras and get to what you
need and just get the hell out of there
without even anybody ever knowing you
were there you can't always do that or
if you can I'm not clever enough to have
figured figured out exactly how to do
that all of the time but and never no
never no thumb over great name is asking
is there difference in the ps4 and Xbox
one versions I believe that the ps4 runs
at a higher resolution
you can sort of tell the xbox version
the xbox one version seems to have a
little bit more you know you notice some
of the jaggies a little bit more and so
on and so forth and I think there's some
differences in the lighting model yeah
you notice those if you go from one to
the other but for all intents and
purposes the on the Xbox one it more or
less looks like the experience I had on
the ps4 yeah I played the Xbox one
version and it didn't set a different
couple making out no these are the same
people right she recently trial wait
wait wait no I think this might be a
different color tired yes just now
recovered an auto accident by cheated
social ties with former friends yeah
that's the mick now drop next to the
rock a lot a sidewalk my favorite bug
that I came across was when this couple
isn't in a bar and they look like
they're like very close to each other
and they're having a conversation I'm
going to do this fixer contract they're
having a conversation but they're both
talking at the same time and both
talking about two different things okay
so it's it's one of those things where
where not only are they not having an
intimate conversation but they're
actually having two conversations at
once I had a situation where Harmony's
the worst I had a situation where I
walked down the street and there were
three different people having the same
conversation yeah that sometimes happen
it's interesting those things stick out
all the more because there's so much
variety in terms of when you hack people
so much Friday in terms of the things
they can actually they can actually be
say and do some of this and people
people of Chicago or have a lot of sex
they say they really do sales there they
also play with themselves a lot as far
as I can tell and girl Draco seven asks
this watchdog's feel like a modern
Assassin's Creed I like is not really
you're like not really I'd say I'd say
far cry 3 X or yes feels more like
Assassin's Creed than this does you can
you can leap over stuff but there's not
and there I guess you could call that
parkour but that doesn't have the same
real feel to it I mean there are
elements the Ubisoft elements here in
terms of the way the systems interlock
yeah unlocks system so that you can get
to other systems so that you can get to
other systems kind of thing and they
jump into pretty quickly yeah they don't
like this essence creation well
Assassin's Creed 3 took yeah several
to really jump in Assassin's Creed for
just moobs yeah I don't you get inside
this one moves pretty much oh wait I
thought I was doing a different kind of
contract I thought I was doing a get
into the car and drive away contact I
didn't contract I didn't realize that I
was doing that's what your target is
doing getting into the car and this is
usually what happens when you get me on
on the on the the show and I Drive it or
I'm not paying any attention I'm gonna
ask you a couple of questions like for
me to really make sure you can't pay
attention and is it interesting to hack
into the phones and other stuff of
random civilians in the game or at one
point you just meet the same people over
and over again there is actually a lot
of variety in terms of the things that
you see and and listen to there is there
is some repetition but I'd say in
general like I probably hacked into
hundreds of people's phones and
typically they've been pretty pretty
varied like I said there they're there
so a lot of the same themes come up like
you come across a lot of Bros talking
about their sexual exploitation
jumpity-jump yeah nice that was done by
a humble planter yeah addicted for that
trees - yeah I noticed that one is
playing is these cars can just tear
through anything yeah these are and
that's what I mean about like the fun
factor of this game is a lot higher than
I expected it's not nearly as serious as
I expected to be sometimes it tries but
really the fun of watchdogs just comes
from you know the pure basic fun of a of
a really great sandbox so does that make
it feel like is it okay with you when it
tries it when you have the mission to
like take on that down the human
traffickers does it like feel like
that's in there just to give you some
evil people or does it like is it okay
like does it feel exploitative to you I
guess is my [ __ ] every so often it feels
a little bit it has a little bit of that
where did he go - I got everyone there
is a little bit of that try too hard
kind of element going on some of the
time like it's like you know we let you
have your fun now we're going to get
serious here we're we're going to talk
about human trafficking and cannibal
and and we're gonna we're going to show
we're going to show a [ __ ] in
progress and that kind of thing
but can you do the mission where you see
a [ __ ] in progress ah Kevin can you
confirm word an argument there's
fighting I'm worried about my place
later tonight where is that no no no
that's uh no that was inappropriate a
live internet tell me I love that look
man this game is rated M for Mature it
was kidding exactly Kevin rated M for
Mature let's go to the story mission and
see what's going on I don't know how
much more time I have but keep going we
got much questions here as well at
boop-she right on the twitch I was
asking what difficulty did you set it to
what did you feel most comfortable with
this is this is on Normal difficulty I
would actually say bump it up too hard
maybe because the the shooting is a
little bit on the easy side okay um
God dudes are pretty quick to go down
when you shoot them even if you shoot
them in the non head areas right which
is to say when you don't shoot them in
the head his leg I yes you know shooting
them in the butt is a perfectly fine
tactic that's like real life she shot
some of the but they'd probably go down
yeah probably
mhmmm forgotten oh I'm just forgettable
underscore username asks does this dude
the main character have any personality
aiden pearce do we care about him yes
you know what I didn't really care that
the whole thing with Aiden is he's kind
of defined by his relationship with his
sister yeah and the fact that he was
trying to get not that kind of
relationship he's trying to eyes always
gotta be well with you O'Dwyer
that's his sister's house there right
yeah going to right now start this
mission they call me what wire so so
basically his thing is okay he's a dude
who's lost a female family member and
now he's out for revenge
it's classic tale only in this case it's
his niece yeah
so a lot of you know the good first half
of the story is really just a bunch of
stuff like that dealing with that so
you're about to go to his sister's son
his nephews birthday birthday party and
there's this is and this is very early
obviously thing yeah this is the second
very very early on so that this this
whole thing is is really interesting
because she's like let it go
stop it yeah
and there's no real good explanation for
why he doesn't stop it yeah
and it's one of my big irritations with
this character is she's like you're
putting us in danger why do you keep
doing that and he's almost is like he
won't do it again and he'll stop and and
as we're about to see and he but he lies
basically you just can't handle it he's
like he just lets himself be pulled in
it's like he doesn't care in that case
he cares more about the revenge quest
than he does about the safety of his
family members the people that he's
originally trying to avenge it it's
really strange and I think that part of
like what keeps him coming back isn't
really sufficiently explored in any
meaningful way and that was the end
things start getting really interesting
like when it gets all Tom Clancy esque
and they're all talking about like like
when he gets his little entourage
together and they're getting all hacky
and hmm you know when it sounds like an
episode of 24 or something and then
suddenly that gets really interesting
and you know there's some interesting
stuff about the man who pulls the
trigger okay that causes the car
accident that his knees dies it they
deal with that in some really
interesting ways and towards the end he
starts to finally get some self
awareness for somebody who seems to be
smart enough to hack into almost
anything yeah he's present hacked into
himself has he no but I should have said
that in the reviewing of your attack of
all let's get let's get this cuz it goes
on for the while see your details but he
doesn't know his oh oh yeah such a
scathing commentary on the modern
condition no it's not
Jackson adore sweet happy birthday I
will say the lighting on the console
versions of this interior can often be
haphazard my kids are playing in a deep
shadow right beneath another funky very
much like because it goes upwards Chris
can't you see that it goes up and
vanishes in the ceiling why would you
have the lights on during the day
because your house is a perpetual den of
darkness and even the lights and also
like can't keep the darkness away so it
does have some overall trick going to
his bedroom there's the the Raving
Rabbids on
the other way yeah there is a rabbit in
there yeah it's pretty good birthday
cake it's the bathroom I know but I'm
picking stuff up she's got good meds
he'll shoot you also pick up like
different compounds and combine them to
make the various hacks teeka sort of
using combat or you can just check out
our emails you absolute posture if you
hack your nephews iPad and hack is rabid
here's the rabbit there that you can you
can hack into things like baseball caps
no does the child have a pacemaker can
you hack into that oh no this is your
sister half of my boss she's getting
called by a creeper well this is the
whole thing this is the whole story bit
now is that now she's being can you
stand really close to her so that she
obviously knows that you're listening in
on the call it breaks the yeah why even
a kin you're just right here you could
probably hear his voice coming out of
the hello coming out of the speaker at
this stage what was that yeah that's
basically what that is it was that what
anyone else see yeah so now this
initiates basically the whole return to
the to the revenge return of the revenge
yep just like that Star Wars movie all
right so he's locating this is obviously
just the game playing at its own way I
feel like I got to take down this is
still part of the unlocking the various
mechanics thing yeah yeah you got to go
murder it out too I'm gonna getcha I
mean I get I'm gonna murder that's what
I do have an unsafe in my nephew's
neighborhood I did find a little bit
weird they'd like to catch people you
like started like auto residence which
are right into you can be fatal
there's like I felt like I felt like
when I killed people by accident in this
world I felt way worse about it like I
know you lose reputation and stuff but I
also felt like this like my niece died
in a car crash up here oh I'm gonna go
out not everybody else's nice car crash
no it's a really is one of those things
that doesn't always make sense like the
gate like the story sometimes tries to
approach stuff like that but not to any
great degree like it's very very
hortence oops it's very very important
that you thought they'd catch the dude
yeah you know Aidan's
you know Aidan's kind of compluvium
to everything that happens around here
yeah he seems like a sociopath just oh
he's just having cars crash into you I
know he do it oh and I wasn't able to do
this the bridge oh there you go what did
you do
took him down yeah I do love how he just
completely beats that absolute crap at
him whoa whoa he's got a gun oh that's
dark homicide can build him in the leg
it's the best kind of kill finish dude
my thing explodes in Chicago it was
worthless as I find the guy who was
prank calling my sister justice it
really is you know I'm tired every
foreigner Jewish so there's one place
and I don't think this is a spoiler
there's one place where he's basically
like so so how's your family yeah I
don't like ain't dude this is how you
got into this mess because somebody was
like getting to your family because of
you now you're just doing the same thing
you're just as much of an [ __ ] as
everybody else and they try to make
something of that in this story they
don't really succeed so just over like
overlook that stuff and just look at
this as a sandbox to have fun in just
have a rag doll button yeah cuz if
you're somebody who thought well gta4
doesn't make any sense how is it that
he's like we're saying he wants so hard
to get out of this life you can go
around murdering random people like if
that drove you crazy
watchdogs is going to make you go like
to literally insane what I will find is
that maybe this is because Ubisoft don't
have much experience and the whole car
driving stuff but the actual driving
itself feels a little bit weird the
driving does feel weird but I have to
say I actually really like the driving
okay um the reason I like the driving is
because it's a little floaty and a
little bouncy some and because even
though the cars aren't cars we recognize
these cars you you know what it's gonna
feel like before you get behind the
wheel and like you can look at it you
can say oh that's a you know that's a
relatively heavy sedan yeah it feels
like a heavy sedan and you get you get
behind motorcycles and and you just I
don't know though I love motorcycles in
this game because they're so fast and so
weightless almost a [ __ ] gamer and the
chat was asking is too much variety in
terms of the vehicles there's a lot of
variety let me see if I can pull over
and I can show you go for jaywehrs walk
into the show so we can just keep going
so okay let me get as long as you're
happy playing let's keep playing yeah
I'll I'll show you and Mark you can you
can order cars on demand and this gives
you an idea sort of of how many
different vehicles you're you're able to
order up you have to you can order a
fire truck yeah some of them are open to
you from the very beginning others you
you're only able to buy and you're only
able to buy them once you've ridden them
in the main world yeah so deal it buy it
then it's on demand you'll buy it and
then it's on demand able basically a
legendary my thrill asks can you shoot
the guy in the leg to make him fall down
this is that is a thing that will happen
yeah but that's not it's not really so
much a boy no it's not really a
meaningful mechanic it's not something
that I found myself doing again because
people die so fast on normal difficulty
so even if you shoot them the leg that
they could actually just perish from
yeah like yeah totally I mean I shot
that dude like four times in some random
place in the body and so that's why I
like buttocks and upper thigh mostly but
there are things you can let's see if
there's a random person to just shoot
you sure so you can do this sort of
slow-mo panic and then sometimes that
can be used in interesting ways like
especially if you really do want to get
that head shot in oh this is a dark but
good thanks heaven's name is terror yeah
I know right
it wasn't like I was an actual combat
encounter so it's okay I just wanted to
show you I didn't want to actually kill
the dude I appreciate your restraint do
you around to around we jump yet but oh
I thought that was around got it Oh
I should be on the Sean method with the
stupid game I said up battery in the
bottom left there's like a limit of the
amount of like hacks there's a limit of
hacks it replenishes but then that that
grows over time so I want to show you
the skill tree for a moment but this is
this doesn't really tell you how big
this skill tree is because at this point
in the game you only have a limited
skill tree so everything's listed for
hacking driving crafting and combat yeah
so usually and and I would suggest this
for anybody the combat is easy enough
well I don't think you're going to need
to worry too much about combat go with
the hacking okay or with the crafting if
you like getting well crafty in this
game either way so additional battery
slot in this case I'm going for bridges
okay cuz hacking into brick my favorite
kind of escape let's show you try and do
that dragon bridge all right let's see
if playing finds you steal a car edge
and do you tend to get enough skill
points you can fit at the entire tree by
the end or do you up do you really nice
5 after 30 hours of playing I still
hadn't unlocked everything okay
but I'd unlock most thing okay I thought
the music in this game was rubbish yeah
what is not good in this game this song
sounds not good but like it is it all
licensed music that they've got from
this part I recognize any songs yeah I
recognize artists I didn't recognize
songs I didn't like I recognize you know
a lot there's a lot of hip-hop in the
end the soundtrack and I recognized most
of the artists but I'd never heard any
of the songs but for me that's it's hard
to say Oh does that mean that I don't
listen to enough to pop or does that but
you don't nation I'm very good Kevin
good good songs but ham so here's here's
so here's a bridge I'll hack into it and
then it starts to raise but this is this
is best used when you're you've got like
somebody on your tail mmm that is that
is when this is its way theater Ashley
there it goes you go I missed it the
first time I wish somebody was on my
tail so I could really show you how fun
that's my favorite kind of escape this
and the the canal escape was to cannot
escape the canal escape is basically
there are no cops in the water
oh whoa did I get try and hit the train
hit the Reg no okay there's this bridge
here I'll do this one
yeah oh that poor guy freaking right is
like Oh what oh he's up and over
yeah Lotus chill video games ah
and I Wow bye off the top rope in a
sports car let's see if affinities asks
did you play this to the keyboard and
mouse on PC at all I haven't played any
of the PC version role actually the
reason for that is because you play
sucks oh yeah it sure does so yeah I
wanted to start playing some of the PC
version today I have not played the past
gen versions either I'm sad to say I
would I play most of the game at a
review event here in San Francisco on
the ps4 and then I played the Xbox one
version at home over the weekend I got
one more question here oops you're right
asks what difficulty or sorry does
difficulty effects the cop chases I did
not notice the difference in how and how
cop chases were handled Oh again like as
far as I could tell the biggest change
was how quickly people went down when
you shot okay
it's interesting though like I would I
would say that the the cop chase is in
general they can big and P they can dog
you pretty hard and that is not a
euphemism in any way there you go watch
dogs they can dog you pretty hard
Kevyn Orr's thank you very much in fact
the last question that came through is
from XD za 1 979 is that a real thing
sure I hope so cuz he says did you make
that up is this number Oh
since once and he wants to salute Kevin
as his new favorite reviewer so your
reviewer of the game is on case with a
car right now yes what it is um I gave
it an 8 because I think it's great nice
you said great what are you drinking
design its wines well it's on wines
water this is water we got branded mug
branded things oh yeah we do but this
this isn't beer in spot you are you're
not you're not honoring my hat
he's hydrating you're honoring me with
your hat and I appreciate it
every day kemberly much obliged I think
we give it away
[Music]